[Music]
you know i killed them
and i killed them too i don't understand
how you could have
so
[Music]
that's impossible how do you do that
i don't know
[Music]
they were found burned but this this
doesn't prove it
[Music]
[Music]
do you believe me now
stop it now i can't
it's your emotions
my name is christine i'm a psychologist
a lot of people are wondering what
happened last night with you and the boy
if you touch me you will burn
eric your embassy has sent some people
to take you back to america
just get in the car
[Music]
you cannot reach a city you do agree
with me right you've seen what he's done
here
i saw it with my own eyes you're lucky
to be alive
sometimes i just get these visions i see
things well like they're different
worlds right i can walk around i can
touch things i can feel things i feel
the wind i feel the heat
i'm not saying he's a bad person
i don't care what he is we need to get
him under control
get out of there as quickly as you can
[Music]
i think something happened that nobody
quite understands yet
[Music]
you